nos piden encontrar la gráfica de la
función fx igual a 5 a la equis y lo
vamos a hacer de la forma más básica
vamos a tomar algunos valores en el
dominio de la función vamos a evaluar la
función en esos valores y eso nos va a
dar las coordenadas de algunos puntos
sobre la gráfica que después podemos
unir para ver cuál es la gráfica ya en
total bueno entonces esta función puede
tomar valores positivos y negativos así
que una vez una buena muestra sería
tomar valores chiquitos que sean
positivos y negativos así que vamos a
ver qué le pasa con los valores de menos
2 a 2 vale entonces déjame de trazar una
tabla por aquí aquí voy a poner una
tabla en donde voy a poner del lado
izquierdo los valores en x y del lado
derecho a los valores en g y como te
comentaba voy a ir de menos 2 a 2
entonces voy a ponerle aquí x igual a
menos 2 si x es igual a menos 2 cuanto
esté efe de menos 2 pues tenemos 5 a la
menos 2 entonces ya sería 5 a la menos 2
porque recuerda que aquí va
igual fx entonces tendríamos 5 a la
menos 2 que usando leyes de los
exponentes es lo mismo que 1 entre 5 al
cuadrado que es igual a 1 sobre 25 muy
bien 1 sobre 25 déjame poner otros los
otros valores antes de hacer la gráfica
para saber cómo tengo que hacer la
escala bueno ahora qué pasa si pongo x
igual a menos 1 si x es igual a menos 1
nos queda 5 a la menos uno que es
simplemente un quinto muy bien vamos con
x igual a cero cualquier número elevado
a la cero es 1 entonces 5 a la cero que
es fx nos quedaría igual a 1 déjame
pasar a otro valor a 1 nos quedaría aquí
5 a la 15 a la 1 es simplemente 5 y nos
queda 5 cualquier número a la 1 es igual
a 5 y finalmente en color verde voy a
poner 2 vale entonces si x es igual a 2
fx es 5 al cuadrado
al cuadrado y 5 al cuadrado es igual a
25 muy bien ya teniendo estos valores y
estos valores podemos hacernos una idea
de cómo tengo que dibujar los ejes
observa que fx siempre es positivo vale
entonces no nos interesa mucho las 'íes'
negativas así que voy a pintar el eje x
así
para entonces esté aquí es el eje x y
voy a pintar el eje empezando de acá
pesando de acá sin pero hacia arriba
hacia allá
ok
y observa que lo puse muy largo en los
valores positivos porque tenemos que
llegar hasta 25 y casi no le hice caso a
los valores negativos porque aquí no hay
vale bueno entonces déjame poner por acá
el menos 2 x igual a menos 2 por aquí
está igual a menos 170 por acá que del 1
y de este lado tenemos el 2
este es el yen aquí tenemos fx y es
igual fx y entonces tengo que llegar
hasta el 25 así que déjame poner por acá
el 25 y a ver si me sale segundo por
aquí quedaría el 5 entonces por acá
quedaría el 10 por acá el 15 más o menos
y por acá el 20 bueno más o menos si si
queda un poquito chueco pues no importa
pero la idea es que aquí están los
valores en llega acá los valores en x y
ahora tenemos que pasar estos puntos
para acá pensando en xy como coordenadas
entonces déjame empezar con el punto
rojo
el punto rojo está en x igual a menos 2
ya igual a 1 sobre 25 1 sobre 25 es un
valor bien chiquito o se hace aquí está
5 por aquí está uno y 1 sobre 25 es la
25 haga parte de eso o sea está súper
pegado al eje x no está sobre el eje x
pero está súper pegado está más o menos
como por aquí es más lo voy a dibujar
pegado pero pero no está pegado si está
tantito encima entonces ahí tenemos el
punto menos 2,1 sobre 25 por aquí está
el 1 sobre 20 voy a escribir 1 sobre 25
más grande que sea un número chiquito no
quiere decir que lo vaya a escribir
chiquito vale bueno entonces 1 sobre 25
entonces aquí está vamos a estar acá y
el menos uno coma un quinto un quinto
también es bien chiquito por aquí está
uno y por acá está un quinto entonces
tenemos un valor como por acá
vale tantito más arriba que el 1 sobre
25 igual está pegadito al eje x pero por
encima del eje
vale luego cuando x es igual a cero es
decir sobre el eje y tenemos que es
igual a 1s si ya queda más arribita ya
queda como por acá nada más que debe ser
de color morado deja tomo el color
morado entonces queda por acá ahí está
el punto 0 1 vámonos al siguiente el
siguiente es el 15 eso ya está un poco
más cómodo de dibujar aquí está el 15 y
finalmente tenemos el 225 2,25 con 25
muy bien entonces sería este punto de
por acá sale listo ya tenemos 5 puntos
que están sobre la gráfica de la función
lo que tenemos que hacer ahora es
conectar estos puntos y observa qué le
sucede a este tipo de funciones que se
llaman funciones exponenciales cuando x
es negativo están súper súper o sea los
valores de la función están súper súper
pegados al eje x
o sea no tocan el eje x no lo cruzan
nunca ni lo tocan son simplemente como
tangentes pero están super super pegados
si x fuera menos un millón estaríamos
pega dificilísimos pero no tocamos el
eje x entonces bueno más o menos la
gráfica vendría como así súper pegada
sigue súper pegada y toca a este valor
de acá
y luego sube tantito más pero no tanto
porque tiene que llegar al 1
entonces empieza a despegar un poquito
más o menos así y llega a este punto de
acá entonces eso es para valores
negativos está muy pegado al eje x pero
en valores positivos se despega empieza
a subir muchísimo de valor vale entonces
aquí llega cruza el eje y la gráfica y
entonces ahora tiene que llegar a este 5
vale entonces tiene que subir
rápidamente pero luego tiene que llegar
al 25 entonces tiene que subir todavía
más rápidamente empieza a ser algo así
más o menos algo así y entonces sube y
sube y sube con locura y desesperación
toque ese punto y se sigue y se sigue y
tiene que subir súper rápido porque al
llegar al 3 ya tiene que estar por el
125 que están cinco veces más arriba que
este valor entonces ahora si esto que
quedó en blanco ya es la gráfica de la
función ya tiene todos los puntos que
están en la gráfica de la función vale
entonces observa en las funciones
exponenciales la gráfica está súper
pegada al eje x cuando los valores son
negativos y cuando los valores son
positivos cuando nos va
de x son positivos la gráfica se despega
terriblemente rápido del eje x y crece y
crece y crece con desesperación a este
dibujito que parece así como una curvita
también se le conoce como palo de
hawking bueno entonces esta es la
gráfica de la función f x igual a 5 a la
x